in terms of nogi who do you think is the
best no-gi competitor of all time
there's no question you know this is
Gordon is
I mean it's
I don't think it's right to say the best
compared of all time because he's still
very young I think that's something that
he came back in the end of when the
person you don't want him to get lazy
you know what I'm saying but you cannot
praise someone in the middle of his
career you know so it's you cannot call
him the best ever he's 26 or 27. so it's
I mean he's he's great he's very good
he's ahead of all of other competitors I
think
and I mean he's having an amazing career
you know he's doing amazingly well
so I mean when he's when he finished
when he finally retired
then you can argue like
you know what there's wisdom in that
it matters how you finish right of
course it's very interesting
I think the nogi is relative new
that nogi scene there was no there
wasn't a scene before
I think you started now on his
generation you know his time because
before
like when I was competing nogi was just
ADCC there's nothing else
every two years and my first was only in
the Emirates you know you should have
you had to go there to compete
so there was not even a scene there was
like this one tournament that gives a
lot of money to
you know to competitors to Fighters and
brings fighters from other modalities
you know to
Marca Venice day or you know some
wrestlers Greco Roman you know they can
compete against each other
and they you know they create that set
of rules try not to favor anyone
so that was it
so you cannot be called
the greatest doggy of all time if you
only have one torment
every two years only in Emirates they
have to be invited to but I think now
you know the degree grew a lot now we
have so many different tournaments now
we have a scene you have people that
only train no gear they're fully
dedicated to nogi then you have
supervised different tournaments so now
it's now you know now it's
professionally you can do just no Gina
which before was unheard of it because
you you have one or two Thomas if you
cannot be called on a Nokia Fighter
fighting one so two once every two years
twice every two years
yeah now there's entire systems that are
optimized for nogi that could be
fundamentally different like what do you
think about the body lock
like this passing with the body lock I I
don't know if you get an understanding
of it yeah that I think it's okay
it's a it's a popular way to
um what is it
to maybe to apply to stay tight just
stay tuned very close to your parent
your your opponent so he can't push
create distance he can push away but
somehow it uh shuts down the hips as
well
yep makes it more difficult to yeah to
kind of trap your legs you'd see your
back gets stuck on against the floor
are you like scientifically
curious about these new developments do
you think do you do you have answers in
your head to them
most
so body lock is one interesting one
obviously foot locks is another and
that'll mean just the full locks but the
whole like control aspect of foot locks
that's interesting and there's other
there's other interesting stuff John is
really into uh
um
the wrestling aspect but not wrestling
wrestling but wrestling everywhere Jiu
Jitsu at all levels of the plane
um that's that's very interesting
because you know obviously you just was
not really been you know unlike like
Freestyle Wrestling and so on has not
been this like a systematic scientific
rigorous exploration of wrestling it's
like you're on your feet and you're on
the ground not
not interesting there's a lot of
interest during his academic he tried to
he knows numbers mathematic everything
well you kind of are too yeah
oh I mean not
I am because you have to understand what
you're doing you know there's a
everything there's a step-by-step
like logistic like details every single
move there's a reason for it you know
there's things around that happens it's
the more you know the better you are
right the more knowledgeable
compare it or whatever
so I think with the foot locks with the
nogi like if you look back
you know if you think of used to be seen
as a really bad thing to attack the foot
it wasn't seen as a good options of
attack
mainly what is a respectable gentleman
don't attack the lake or what no because
if you look back you know the Thomas the
when they were created all the rules and
everything else was to simulate a real
fight with no punches but now we're
having a ghee I mean if you ask what is
Jiu Jitsu like what are you trying
what's the main goal of jiu jitsu to
dominate your opponent what's the middle
of fighting
is we fighting it's of course submission
is the ultimate goal
but the the you know before that the
main goal is to dominate you like we're
fighting I have to dominate you and then
the submission comes
and foot locks it's I don't require any
domination on you I don't I I don't need
to be in a dominant position to attack
your foot and is this if I attack your
foot you're still free to knock me out
if your body goes down to my foot I can
still come close to your stand up and
I'll punch you so it's not a good
position to be in a real fight
yeah try attacking the foot I mean how
many times you've seen that going bad
that went bad in in MMA fight I mean of
course you had so you know some sort of
success with the hookup it's no
questions but how many times went wrong
people were knocked out attacking the
foot so you can't say it's the best
position to be
it's it's okay to go but it's a very
high risky position to go so that's why
it's not in a real situation it's not
seen as a good thing
so when you translate that to Jujitsu
when attacking the foot is not seen as a
good thing because when you reflect that
tour to a real situation it's not going
to go down well
so he was always seen as a as an easy
way out you know easy cut you're trying
you're trying to do the easy path you
can't pass my guard you can't dominate
me and then you're trying to attack my
foot that's why I was always seen as a
you know it's not as the best a great
submission to which win but the sad side
effect of that is it was completely
underdeveloped because of that
of course so people never really
developed that but now they do the
torments the fighting it got completely
not completely but you got some it's not
longer seen as you know as a simulation
of the real thing now is a another sport
it's only seen as a sport so now it
doesn't matter if you attack my foot you
cannot punch me so why is it bad now to
attack the foot
this is not seen as a bad thing anymore
and it now it got really developed
I don't know that's another
Bear versus Shark question but you know
there is
um
in a street self-defense situation it's
possible to imagine where foot locks
would be effective for a highly but I
guess if you invest 10 000 hours it's
better to invest it in chokes yeah to
dominate you if I'm you know if I were
fighting it's way better for me to be on
your side control on the mount where I
can pin you'll be completely safe
then to stay inside your legs trying to
attack your foot
but people would argue that there's a
lot of very dominant controlling
positions in the whole football game
right it is but it can go bad very
quickly yeah just no it I mean this
there's some great ways to control
someone that he cannot Escape but it can
go bad very quickly that's the thing
well even back control can go bad very
quickly on the street
so Mount I don't know is mount a really
good position but then then there's no
good position then
there's no every every position there's
a risk okay
attacking the foot is a way higher risk
than side control mouth back
as I'm saying the back is not the best
way to pin someone unless you underneath
me
because I if you try to rotate I can
sacrifice the back and just allow you
push be in the mouth okay there you go
would you prefer Mount or back Mount or
they're flattened like uh
a steel mat
[Laughter]
uh so yeah going back to Gordon what do
you think makes that guy so good we were
just a ADCC got to see him uh
historically dominant first performance
his dedication
the way he trains and how much he trains
and of course you have to add his mind
his belief
to really try to be good
the best or you know I don't know what
his goals are but I know he's trying to
be better than his opponents so his
belief are very strong
his dedication he probably trains more
than everybody else
I mean I'm I haven't seen firsthand it
but from what I hear interviews with him
and everybody else training I you know
the way everybody trains yeah you know
trying to for my
uh little knowledge I have I I'll bet he
trains more than everybody else and most
important how he trains
and when I I kind of already knew but
when I heard John podcast with you the
other day John was explaining that
preparation the training for the ADCC
and that kind of gave me a very strong
idea how they've been training all these
years
so you know when we said it's you have
to work on your weakness so you have no
weakness
he trains a lot on his weakness which
not everyone does that you know if you
look other I'm not gonna name but you
know or the main schools when like very
strong competitors great comparatives so
super tough people
but super tough
not great
because they train this bar very hard
that makes them tough
if you want to be good you have to work
on your weakness
because
when you spawn like we're saying how
many times you're gonna practice
Escape in a bad position like a
submission hold or a pinning position
side control Mount or this very little
the amount time you get to spend on
those positions if you don't start there
so that
he's very smart the way he trains and
part of that is also cerebral it's not
just putting yourself in those positions
but talking through different ideas like
they they talk
they like experiment
it's very like at at first glance it's
like philosophical almost
is you're trying to create systems
constantly trying to understand how this
fits into this big picture and and then
it goes back to what is Jiu Jitsu what
is fighting he's fighting for dominance
you know he's fighting for the ultimate
dominance positions which is back him
out there's no others and from that you
finish so if you look back at his you
know over the years thought you know of
his past fights
before he used to mainly focus in legs
and over the past few years now he's
mainly focusing in
finishing from the mountain back
but that's when he became really good